We also had questions about other ways to host your web app.
Right now we're using Google AppEngine, but there are plenty of other alternatives,
and some of them are Amazon AWS, Linode, Rackspace--
if you Google web application hosting services, you should probably find
many, many options.
Amazon AWS is what Steve uses for Hipmunk.
I believe it's what he used for Reddit as well,
and he really likes AWS, and he would recommend it.
There are plenty of other options, though,
and plenty of other options where you can use Python.
Migrating it from one service to another can be a little bit complicated.
And depending on the size of your web application, it can be worth it,
or it can be something that you really don't want to do
just because it would take your application offline,
or it'd just be too much complication to deal with at the time.
We're going to be talking about that a lot more in Unit 7.
Unit 7 is basically going to be about the problems that Steve has run into himself
in building web applications and the solutions he came up with,
the solutions he wished he came up with, and things like that.
There were a lot of questions related to that:
how to migrate from one service to another,
how to come up with an idea and pitch it to people,
how to make sure that lots of people see your site and can find your site.
So we'll be going over all those kinds of questions in Unit 7.
So stick around!